Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是 Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我与商业导师 Lisa Johnson 共同发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. On today's episode, I am joined by Fiona, an assistant psychologist. We talk about starting
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由 Lisa 本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的专属链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent 博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天做客节目的嘉宾是助理心理学家 Fiona。我们聊到了开启
a career in psychology, taking a different path and then coming back to psychology. We also talk about trauma-informed yoga practices, being a parent and many, many more things. Stay tuned right to the end to get Fiona's top tip for reducing burnout in aspiring psychologists. with this podcast that feels sad to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Trent Hi welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast I Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Today's episode is so action-packed and I'm so excited for you
心理学职业生涯、走过弯路后再回归心理学的经历。我们还讨论了创伤知情瑜伽练习、为人父母以及许多其他话题。请务必听到最后，获取 Fiona 关于减少准心理学家职业倦怠的宝贵建议。欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》，我是 Marianne Trent 博士。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》，我是临床心理学家 Marianne Trent 博士。今天的节目内容非常丰富，我非常期待你们
to meet our guests and for you to learn more about them and their journey. Fiona Jenkins is in her early 40s and she reached out to me because she discovered the podcast and was finding it really useful. She's got so many interesting viewpoints and I hope you find today's episode really useful. I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi Fiona, welcome along to today's episode of the podcast. Thanks for joining us. Thanks for having me. So as I did say in the intro, you contacted me. So we first made contact via Facebook, which is a little bit different for me because I'm usually hanging out on LinkedIn and latterly Twitter as well. But you got in contact because you said you've been following the podcast for a while and you thought you had sort of interesting interestingly different narrative and I'm always
见到我们的嘉宾，并了解她们的故事。Fiona Jenkins 今年四十出头，她联系我是因为她发现了这个播客，并觉得非常有帮助。她有很多有趣的观点，希望今天的节目对你也有所启发。稍后见。嗨 Fiona，欢迎来到今天的节目。感谢你的参与。谢谢你的邀请。正如我在开场白中所说，是你主动联系我的。我们最初是在 Facebook 上取得联系的，这对我来说有点特别，因为我通常活跃在 LinkedIn 和最近的 Twitter 上。但你联系我是因为你说你关注这个播客有一段时间了，并且认为自己有一个
so interested in anybody's experience of psychology but can you tell me in your own words why why you reached out Fiona? Yes so I became aware of your podcast I think when I was searching for more information about the CAP role so the clinical associate in psychology role because that's something that had come come on my radar so you know how on the podcast app you can just search for anything it'll bring up podcasts about it so I did that and that's how I first became aware of your podcast. And then I went back, listened to some previous episodes. I've read the book, not the Aspiring Psychologist one, the Clinical Psychologist Collective, which was really interesting and useful
非常独特且有趣的叙事。我一直对任何人的心理学经历都很感兴趣，但你能用自己的话告诉我，你为什么联系我吗，Fiona？好的，我想我是在搜索关于 CAP（临床心理学助理）角色的更多信息时发现了你的播客，因为这个角色引起了我的关注。你知道在播客应用里，你可以搜索任何内容，它就会弹出相关的播客，我就是这样第一次发现你的节目的。然后我回去听了之前的一些剧集。我还读了那本书，不是《有志心理学家》那本，而是《临床心理学家集体》，那本书非常有趣且实用，
and kind of gave me that sense of possibility. Oh, okay, maybe this isn't um impossible actually so thank you gosh you're trying to make me cry you didn't you didn't tell me you didn't tell me any of that in the messages that's so lovely so you know what that tells me is that what I'm doing is shaping lives and inspiring and just making people a little bit curious and a little bit you know explorative um is that even a word explorative yeah I'm not sure yeah because you're so consistent you know putting out content every week uh it's reliable you know sometimes it's short but doesn't matter because it's it's it's reliably coming through every week so it's like you know sometimes it's short but doesn't matter because it's it's it's reliably
它给了我一种“可能性”的感觉。哦，原来这并非不可能。所以，谢谢你，天哪，你快把我弄哭了。你在信息里可没跟我提过这些，真是太感人了。你知道这说明了什么吗？说明我所做的事情正在塑造生命，激励他人，让人们产生好奇心，去探索……“探索性”这个词是这么用的吗？我不太确定，哈哈。因为你非常坚持，每周都发布内容，非常可靠。你知道，有时内容很短，但这没关系，因为每周都能准时收到，就像
coming through every week so it's like this drip feed of compassionate stuff which we all need oh thank you that's really lovely so tell me a little bit about how that inspired you to go on to get the role that you've got now then Fiona? So I think I was looking around at the CAP role because I can't even remember if that was before or after I got this assistant role but basically well I'll start right from the beginning, Marianne. It's quite a long story, but I'll start from the beginning. So I did a psychology degree over 20 years ago, and I was always interested in becoming a psychologist. So after graduating, I had a support worker role, and then I had an assistant psychologist role. I had a couple, actually. The first one was not a typical
每周都在持续更新，这就像是一种充满同情心的“滴灌”，是我们所有人都需要的。哦，谢谢你，这太暖心了。那么，请告诉我，这如何激励你获得了现在这份工作呢，Fiona？我想当时我正在关注 CAP 角色，因为我不记得那是在我获得这份助理工作之前还是之后了。但基本上，Marianne，我从头说起吧。这是一个很长的故事，但我会从头讲起。我在 20 多年前获得了心理学学位，一直对成为心理学家很感兴趣。毕业后，我做过支持工作者，然后做过助理心理学家。其实我做过两份，第一份并不典型，
one if you think we're going back to the early 2000s so quite a long time ago and myself and three others we were employed by the NHS but we were seconded to a youth offending service and we were doing family therapy like systemic therapy and that was a really big job for a sort of 22 year old um and they've since given that role to social workers which I think shows the kind of role that it is or was um so I did that for about a year. It involved driving around the county, visiting the families of young offenders. They were often single mums with, you know, a giant teenager who was bigger than them, stronger than them. And there was me, you know, not really with any life experience trying to tell these single mums how to parent. I mean, now I am a a parent but back then I really knew
如果你考虑到那是 21 世纪初，那是很久以前的事了。当时我和另外三个人受雇于英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS），但被借调到青少年犯罪服务部门，我们从事家庭治疗，也就是系统式治疗。对于一个 22 岁左右的人来说，这是一份非常重大的工作。后来他们把这个职位给了社会工作者，我认为这说明了这份工作的性质。我做了大约一年，工作内容包括开车在全县奔波，探访年轻罪犯的家庭。他们通常是单亲妈妈，带着一个比她们更高、更壮的青少年。而我，没什么生活经验，却试图教这些单亲妈妈如何管教孩子。说实话，现在我自己也是个家长了，但当时我真的
nothing and I felt that you know. I tried my best with what we were given, the model and everything but it was a very stressful time. I remember supervision, you know no disrespect to my supervisor but she was very stressed and so it was you know sometimes it felt like I was supporting her rather than the other way around so it was kind of this imperfect system so I got out of that one and did another role and then I started another one and I just I it was all just too much too soon I think and I sort of had this feeling like I'm in my early 20s, life should be about fun. It should be more fun than this. I'm not enjoying this.
什么都不懂，我感觉到了这一点。我尽力运用我们所学的模型，但那是一段压力很大的时期。我记得督导过程，并不是对我的督导不敬，但她当时压力也非常大，所以有时感觉是我在支持她，而不是她在支持我。那是一个不完美的系统。所以我离开了那份工作，又做了另一份，但我感觉一切都来得太快、太沉重了。我当时 20 出头，觉得生活应该是充满乐趣的，不该是这样。我不喜欢这份工作。
So I decided to get out. I'd heard from one of my colleagues at the Youth Offending Service about the JET program, which is a program for graduates to go to Japan and teach in government schools. So I applied for that, but I had a kind of a year to fill before I went there. So I went to Russia for a year. And then I went to Japan, and I ended up spending five years there, ended up meeting my husband, getting married, having a baby. So it was totally life changing experience. Then we decided to move back to the UK.
所以我决定离开。我从青少年犯罪服务部门的一位同事那里听说过 JET 项目，这是一个让毕业生去日本政府学校任教的项目。我申请了，但在去之前我有一年的空档期。于是我去了俄罗斯一年，然后去了日本，在那里待了五年，遇到了我的丈夫，结婚并生了孩子。那是一次彻底改变人生的经历。后来我们决定搬回英国。
So he's American, not from here. But we decided to try living here. And I, well, I tried various different things, including using my Japanese, including trying teacher training. But I don't know, none of it felt really right. Then I had a daughter and while I was on maternity leave I started volunteering and training to be a mum's mental health peer support worker for you know maternal mental health with NCT the National Child Birth Trust. So I was a peer support worker and a breastfeeding peer support worker while I was on maternity leave and for a bit of time after but I sort of realized that I couldn't really work for free sadly and my manager in that the NCT role had noticed some peer support worker roles in the NHS and she sent them to us and I applied for one of those so I started working as a peer support worker
他是个美国人，不是本地人。但我们决定尝试在这里生活。我尝试了各种不同的事情，包括利用我的日语能力，尝试教师培训。但不知道为什么，感觉都不太对。后来我生了女儿，在产假期间，我开始志愿服务并接受培训，成为一名 NCT（英国全国分娩信托）的母亲心理健康同伴支持工作者。在产假期间及之后的一段时间里，我一直担任同伴支持工作者和母乳喂养同伴支持工作者。但我意识到，遗憾的是我不能一直免费工作。我在 NCT 的经理注意到了 NHS 的一些同伴支持工作者职位，并转发给了我们，我申请了其中一个。于是我开始在我的信托机构担任同伴支持工作者，
in my trust and then I'd been doing that for about I guess two years when this email came through saying do you have a psychology degree and would you like experience as an assistant on a secondment and I thought would I maybe I would maybe I should get back into this which you know something that it felt like that door had closed for me but this was an opening again and it you had to be working already in the trust so the idea was sort of taking from the the pool of talent who are were already working in the trust and kind of giving them a helping hand in a way because as we know these AP roles are so competitive so yeah I applied and we had quite an intense group interview and then we had a one-to-one interview or three-to-one three of them one of me and I was placed in an older adults service and I've been there since December so that is the very long story of how I got here. Gosh amazing what a story and I had heard of JET
做了大约两年后，我收到了一封邮件，问我是否有心理学学位，是否想获得一份助理心理学家的借调经验。我想，也许我可以，也许我应该重回这个领域。这扇门曾经对我关闭了，但现在又重新打开了。而且要求必须已经在信托机构工作，所以这个想法是从已经在机构工作的优秀人才库中选拔，并给予他们帮助，因为我们都知道这些助理心理学家的职位竞争非常激烈。所以我申请了，经历了非常紧张的集体面试，然后是一对一面试（其实是三对一）。我被分配到了老年人服务部门，从去年 12 月起就一直在那里工作。这就是我走到今天这一步的漫长故事。天哪，太棒了，真是个精彩的故事。我听说过 JET 项目，
because one of my friends actually was on the JET program probably a similarish time to you and now does have a Japanese wife she's lovely um and they live in the UK as well so I had heard of that but I don't think I've is it still going I haven't heard of it since it is yeah it's it's still going strong and I've told my son who was born there you know you you could apply to this when you're a bit older you're a jet baby and you can explain that you know this is where you originated I love that so you actually did spend quite a period of time then if you had your baby um your first child um there then yeah yeah and it was really perspective changing in many ways I mean um it gave me this experience of being different
因为我的一位朋友当时也参加了 JET 项目，时间和你差不多，现在他娶了一位日本妻子，人很好，他们也住在英国。所以我听说过这个项目，但不知道它还在运行吗？是的，它依然非常活跃。我告诉我在那里出生的儿子，等你大一点的时候也可以申请，你是“JET 宝宝”，你可以解释说这就是你的起源地。我喜欢这个说法。所以你确实在那里待了很长一段时间，因为你的第一个孩子是在那里出生的。是的，这在很多方面改变了我的视角。它给了我一种“作为异类”的体验，
it was largely positive because I have the privilege of being white blonde hair blue eyes you know in Japanese eyes seen as this sort of western ideal almost so it was largely positive attention but i mean it did give me that experience of feeling like people are talking about me a lot behind my back you know i felt a bit of paranoia because it was true we were being talked about behind our backs or just in front of us yeah so it was a really different experience and you know the culture is very different to ours very kind of collective rather than individual and yeah lots of really great experiences thought-provoking experiences. Yeah yeah I think you know you described so powerfully the the brilliance and the what we can learn what we can value about going out and seeing in person
这种体验大部分是积极的，因为我有幸拥有白皮肤、金发、蓝眼睛，在日本被视为一种西方理想。所以大部分是积极的关注，但它确实让我体验到了那种“人们在背后议论我”的感觉。我感到有点多疑，因为那是真的，我们确实在被议论，有时甚至就在我们面前。所以这是一种非常不同的体验。而且那里的文化与我们非常不同，更倾向于集体主义而非个人主义。有很多非常棒的、发人深省的经历。是的，你非常有力地描述了走出去亲眼见证不同文化所带来的价值。
different cultures for ourselves so as you were speaking it reminded me of being in Thailand and I was quite a lot younger and quite a lot blonder then um and people follow chasing me down the street calling me Cameron Diaz and I was like Cameron Diaz like Cameron Cameron I was like I'm really not Cameron Diaz like um and then when I was in um India just before I started my clinical training we were quite a remote um area and we were at the cinema and my friends and I were in the atrium waiting to go in and see a Bollywood movie and we were just surrounded with a ring of local people eating their popcorn watching us and sort of pointing and laughing like oh like we were zoo like zoo creatures like what are they gonna do next what are they gonna do next but it was really really interesting to be part of that experience and to just allow it to happen as well you know
当你说话时，让我想起了我在泰国的时候，那时我更年轻，头发也更金。人们在街上追着我喊“卡梅隆·迪亚兹”，我当时想，卡梅隆·迪亚兹？我真的不是卡梅隆·迪亚兹。后来在临床培训开始前，我在印度一个偏远地区，我们在电影院大厅等着看宝莱坞电影，周围围了一圈当地人，吃着爆米花看着我们，指指点点，像看动物园里的生物一样，想看看我们接下来要做什么。但能参与那种体验并顺其自然，真的非常有趣。
yes and I feel it served me well in ways like you have to be really tolerant of uncertainty you have to sit with being really uncomfortable quite regularly because maybe you know when I first got there I knew no Japanese I really didn't know what was going on a lot of the time it was very awkward a lot of the time and I think that's really served me well actually going forwards in now I'm much I find it much easier to sit with uncertainty and just, you know, just deal with it and deal with those uncomfortable feelings. OK, so you obviously you've learned a lot in the in the kind of it's not a sidestep, is it? But just in a different trajectory from doing the kind of Japanese chapter of your life but do you think what might have made the difference or what might have yeah given you a slightly shorter journey to where
是的，我觉得它在很多方面对我很有帮助。你必须非常包容不确定性，必须经常忍受那种不适感。比如刚到那里时，我不懂日语，很多时候根本不知道发生了什么，非常尴尬。我认为这对我现在的发展很有帮助，我发现自己更容易接受不确定性，并处理那些不舒服的感觉。好的，你显然在这一过程中学到了很多，这不仅仅是一个侧步，而是你人生中一段不同的轨迹。你觉得是什么让你走到了今天，或者说是什么让你通往现在的路稍微缩短了一些？
you are now what did you need so I've been you know it is a heavy role working in youth justice with teenagers that are really really cool cool, really, really street smart. I absolutely felt that pressure. I wasn't going to people's homes. I was in the prison. So that kind of probably helped with some of that balance. But I definitely didn't feel cool enough to do that. Definitely didn't. Was there anything that might have made a difference in terms of your roles in the UK that might have been the difference that made the difference for you? I mean I think to a certain extent for my own personal journey I probably needed to get out of the UK and get out of those roles and kind of come back now full circle back to psychology but okay I mean great supervision would would have probably made a big difference because I know this because I'm now lucky enough to be getting that great
我在青少年司法部门工作，面对那些非常酷、非常精明的青少年，这确实是一份沉重的工作。我感受到了压力。我不是去家里探访，而是在监狱里。这可能有助于平衡心态。但我绝对觉得自己不够“酷”去胜任那份工作。在英国的职位中，有什么因素是让你产生改变的关键吗？我认为在某种程度上，为了我个人的成长，我可能需要离开英国，离开那些角色，然后兜兜转转回到心理学。但如果说有什么能带来巨大改变的话，那就是优秀的督导。我现在很幸运能得到那种我当时没有的优秀督导，这带来了巨大的不同。
supervision that I didn't have back then and that has made a big difference so I'd say it's two things it's me personally developing and growing up but also that support yeah yeah absolutely and I think when we become parents it for me anyway I can't speak for you I can't speak for other parents it just changes everything about everything it changes how I relate to people it changes how human I am I feel like before becoming a parent it definitely felt like there was a work persona and a sort of home persona like a genuine personality I think it's reminding me of some of the personality development theories around crystallized intelligence and crystallized personality so some random rumbling
所以我认为有两点：我个人的成长和成熟，以及那种支持。是的，绝对是这样。而且我认为当我们成为父母后——至少对我来说是这样，我不能代表其他人——它改变了一切。它改变了我与人相处的方式，改变了我作为人的本质。我觉得在成为父母之前，我有一个“工作人格”和一个“家庭人格”。这让我想起了一些关于结晶智力和结晶人格的理论，我脑子里乱七八糟的想法。
that's going on in my brain about that and I felt like before they were quite separate whereas I think becoming a parent and then probably the pandemic has meant that it's all just for me I am the intervention and it's I'm more the same person across all of the settings now have you experienced anything like that in your parenting journey that's really interesting you say that because for me it's almost the opposite I feel so boundaried I feel so lucky that I have my family life and I have no choice but to really just switch modes from work to home and especially with time boundaries you know because I can't stay late because I have to leave at that time to go and pick up my daughter from after school care so for me it's very separate. But yeah, in terms of bringing yourself to the work,
我觉得以前它们是分开的，但成为父母以及经历疫情后，对我来说，这一切都融合了。我就是干预本身，我在所有环境中的表现都更加一致了。你在育儿过程中有过类似的体验吗？你这么说很有趣，因为对我来说恰恰相反。我感到界限感非常强。我很幸运拥有家庭生活，我别无选择，只能在工作和家庭模式之间切换，尤其是时间界限，因为我不能加班，必须准时去接女儿放学。所以对我来说，它们是非常分开的。但就将自我投入到工作中而言，
of course, it changes you on some fundamental level. Yeah. Yeah, there's nothing like knowing that you're going to get charged a late fee to make sure that you leave work on time. And I find that's quite useful, actually, in terms of, because sometimes we can, you know, I was listening to that song People Pleaser earlier. I don't know if you've heard that. She was the lady that capped someone or other was singing it at Glastonbury yesterday.
当然，它在某种程度上改变了你。是的，没有什么比知道自己会因为迟到而被罚款更能让你准时下班的了。我发现这在某种程度上很有用。因为有时我们……我之前听过那首《讨好者》（People Pleaser）的歌，不知道你听过没。昨天在格拉斯顿伯里音乐节上有人唱了这首歌。
And I was listening to it. It's a good song. And I think many of us as psychologists can be people pleasers. What I like about about children is they give you a really nice way of saying no and being assertive and being bounded without it making it like you're being difficult you know no I do actually want to finish work at five so I'm gonna because I'm really sorry you know I've got to because I've got to pick my kid up but I also think for people who aren't parents we as a society should allow people to leave at five because their job finishes at five and we shouldn't have to use an excuse and I feel quite strongly about you know caring for the carers this is one of my real interests is like who is looking after these people who are looking after some of the most traumatized or damaged members of society this is going to have a knock
我听了，那是一首好歌。我想我们很多心理学家都容易成为讨好者。我喜欢孩子的一点是，他们给了你一种很好的方式去说“不”，去坚定立场，去设定界限，而不会让你显得难以相处。比如，“不，我确实想在五点结束工作，所以我得走了，很抱歉，因为我得去接孩子。”但我认为对于非父母的人，社会也应该允许他们在五点下班，因为工作就是五点结束，我们不应该需要找借口。我非常强烈地认为要“关怀照护者”，这是我真正的兴趣所在：谁在照顾那些照顾社会中最受创伤或受损群体的人？如果我们不照顾好员工，这会产生连锁反应。
on effect if we're not looking after staff and that's one thing I'm really really interested in is bringing more care to the people doing the work I think it's so needed. Yeah so I'm absolutely aware of the impact of vicarious trauma and how we need to think about supporting our staff. But this also reminds me of a conversation I was having on Twitter in May. The British Psychological Society had really been trying to build people's awareness of the fact that the NHS wellbeing hubs that were set up to support staff during the pandemic are actually no longer going to be funded, or that was the plan at that stage. And Stephen Fry had got on board with a video, which was sort of rallying the troops to really think about trying to encourage the government to continue to fund those. So, you know, one of the
我非常关注如何为从事这项工作的人提供更多关怀，我认为这非常必要。是的，我完全意识到替代性创伤的影响，以及我们需要考虑如何支持员工。这让我想起了五月份我在 Twitter 上的一次对话。英国心理学会一直在努力提高人们的意识，即在疫情期间为支持员工而设立的 NHS 健康中心将不再获得资助，或者当时计划是这样。斯蒂芬·弗莱（Stephen Fry）也参与进来，录制了一段视频，呼吁大家鼓励政府继续资助这些中心。所以，
roles of this podcast is to talk about um you know current themes and debates in psychology so if you are listening to this and you're interested in that do check out um that uh that movement um on twitter and i'll make sure i put a link um in the show notes for anybody that wants to easily catch up on that too so yeah really really interesting and really useful stuff so thanks for bringing that to our awareness Fiona and it also made me think about when I was in services I didn't have children when it came to sort of divvying up leave at Christmas there was a definite kind of suggestion that probably I ought to to do it and so I probably just did do it because I definitely felt like oh it'd be nice for them to have time with their children but what we learn when we become parents or even before and
这个播客的角色之一就是讨论心理学中的当前主题和辩论。如果你正在收听并对此感兴趣，请务必查看 Twitter 上的那个运动，我会确保在节目笔记中放一个链接，方便大家了解。这真的非常有趣且实用，感谢你让大家关注到这一点，Fiona。这也让我想起我在服务部门工作时，还没有孩子。圣诞节分配假期时，有一种明确的暗示，认为我应该承担更多工作，所以我可能就真的做了，因为我觉得让有孩子的同事多陪陪家人很好。但当我们成为父母，或者在此之前，
we give ourselves permission to take a nice long break of sort of two weeks it's how good that feels doesn't it uh completely switch off from work yeah so it's yeah thinking about treating people as humans and regardless of their parenting status isn't it yeah so we are a similar age I think as I went to university in 1999 I just turned 42 very recently so yeah it's interesting that we had largely similar experiences but we've you know come to a similar-ish place but different trajectories so is your plan clinical are you sort of heading in that direction? I think I'm going to give it a go I think one of the benefits of being older is feeling like if it doesn't work out there are many many more options open to me and I don't feel like it's the be-all and end-all which I think is a really
我们给自己许可去休一个两周的长假，那种感觉真好，不是吗？完全从工作中抽离出来。所以，无论人们是否为人父母，把他们当作人来对待，这很重要。我们年龄相仿，我是在 1999 年上大学的，刚满 42 岁。所以我们有相似的经历，但走出了不同的轨迹。你的计划是临床方向吗？你是在朝那个方向努力吗？我想我会试一试。我认为年长的一个好处是，你会觉得如果行不通，还有很多其他选择。我不觉得这是唯一的出路，我认为这是一种非常
internally powerful position to be in because really I think yeah I can see so many different options as I mentioned to you I'm a yoga teacher as well so I'm lucky enough to be doing this role part-time this assistant role part-time and on my other days I teach yoga I've got a class going or a group going for community mental health service users, which is paid for by the NHS. So I feel there's a, you know, another path I could take if the clinical route doesn't work out. But ideally, I'd like to be sort of using both in my work, you know using the body as well as the mind um so yes I'll give it go I'll make an application and see how I get on but with quite low expectations as it's been it's been a long time since I've done academic work I'm I'm possibly getting involved in some research
内在强大的心态。我确实看到了很多不同的选择。正如我提到的，我还是个瑜伽老师，我很幸运能兼职做这份助理工作，在其他日子里我教瑜伽。我有一个为社区心理健康服务使用者开设的课程，由 NHS 资助。所以我觉得如果临床路线走不通，我还有另一条路可以走。但理想情况下，我希望在工作中结合两者，既运用身体也运用头脑。所以我会试一试，提交申请看看结果如何，但我期望值很低，因为我已经很久没有进行学术工作了。我可能还会参与一些研究，
on one of my days um I'm exploring that because that's my kind of weak point. Not weak, but rusty point because it's been such a long time. So we'll see. I'll give myself a few tries, maybe two tries. But I can't, you know, keep on trying and trying for many years. I don't think that would be good for me although I admire people who can do that who have the stamina yeah you get to decide don't you and I really love the book I'm not sure if you read it um the body holds the score and that talks about trauma-informed yoga which is really powerful. I think they give an example of childbirth. If somebody's had a traumatic birth, then sometimes getting themselves back in that birth position
在我的空闲时间里，我正在探索这一点，因为那是我的弱项。不是弱，而是生疏了，因为太久没做了。所以我们会看看。我会给自己几次机会，也许两次。但我不能一直尝试很多年，我不认为这对我有好处，尽管我很钦佩那些有毅力坚持下去的人。是的，你可以自己决定。我很喜欢那本书，不知道你读过没，《身体从未忘记》（The Body Keeps the Score），它谈到了创伤知情瑜伽，非常有力量。他们举了分娩的例子，如果某人经历过创伤性分娩，那么有时让自己回到那种分娩姿势，
can suddenly make them feel really scared and really vulnerable and really out of control. And it's because the body has held the score. It's remembered that that's a stress position and that's something, you know, no good's going to come from that. So it's really, really interesting work. Yes, it is. So I've done a bit of trauma-informed yoga teacher training in order to lead this class in the community um and yeah the sort of things we learned it's so fascinating another really great book is um trauma and recovery by Judith Herman, which I recommend to all of your listeners, as a psychologist as well as a yoga teacher. And what was I going to say?
会突然让他们感到非常害怕、脆弱和失控。这是因为身体记住了创伤，它记得那是一个压力姿势，知道那不会带来什么好结果。所以这是一项非常有趣的工作。是的，确实如此。为了在社区开展这个课程，我接受了一些创伤知情瑜伽教师培训。我们学到的东西非常迷人。另一本很棒的书是朱迪思·赫尔曼（Judith Herman）的《创伤与复原》，我向所有听众推荐，作为心理学家和瑜伽老师，我都推荐这本书。我想说什么来着？
Oh, yes. So a lot of this thinking about trauma is that it's kind of pre verbal so actually working with the body can be more helpful to someone than working with words so I believe in both I really believe in the power of talking therapies but for some people maybe that won't work and for them doing some work in the body will be more healing or they'll make more of a breakthrough. Yeah, so I'm very keen to explore all this more.
哦，对了。关于创伤的很多思考是，它是前语言的，所以与身体工作有时比与语言工作对某些人更有帮助。我相信两者，我非常相信谈话疗法的力量，但对某些人来说，也许那行不通，通过身体工作会更有疗愈效果，或者能取得突破。是的，我非常渴望深入探索这一切。
There's so many things I'm interested in, Marianne. It's difficult to find the time to pursue all these interests, but I have got the rest of my life you know the second half of my life so I will just crack on with it all. Well done it sounds really brilliant and you know even being able to kind of pitch your services to an NHS organisation and having them go for it that's not that's no mean feat you know you've done really well there as well how is the class going how are the participants finding it so this is i think about the third or fourth i think it's the fourth round that we've run so it's me and an occupational therapist take the group and um yeah we've had some really positive feedback in the previous rounds um I think the people vote with their feet, don't they? So the
我感兴趣的事情太多了，Marianne。很难找到时间去追求所有这些兴趣，但我还有下半辈子呢，所以我打算继续努力。做得好，这听起来太棒了。即使是能够向 NHS 机构推销你的服务并获得认可，这也不是一件容易的事，你做得非常好。课程进行得怎么样？参与者感觉如何？我想这大概是我们开展的第三或第四轮了。我和一位职业治疗师共同负责这个小组，我们在之前的几轮中收到了一些非常积极的反馈。我想人们会用脚投票，对吧？所以
people who stay and come to the whole 10 sessions, that is the best kind of compliment because we know that they must be finding it helpful. And for some people, we're keen to emphasise that for some people, it might be might be really actually they won't feel better after they might feel worse they might feel terrible after this one hour session um but that is normal and to know that you know it might not be for them or they might want to try it for the 10 weeks and see if anything changes for them or they might want to carry on for 10 years and see if anything changes for them um but yeah we're having people coming back and staying so that is a compliment so we think it's it's useful to at least some of our group members good and i've got
那些留下来并参加全部 10 次课程的人，就是最好的赞美，因为我们知道他们一定觉得有帮助。对于某些人，我们强调，有些人可能在课程结束后不会感觉更好，甚至可能感觉更糟，可能会在这一小时的课程后感到非常糟糕。但这很正常，他们可能会意识到这不适合他们，或者他们可能会坚持 10 周看看是否有变化，或者坚持 10 年看看是否有变化。但确实有人回来并留了下来，这就是一种赞美。所以我们认为这对我们小组中的至少一部分人是有用的。很好，我还有
so many questions for you i'm so interested in everything you're saying. So one part of me thinks, are you outcome measuring it? Are you measuring your change? Are you demonstrating it? So very good question and very pertinent because I have just started this introduction to evaluation course which is also offered for free which I found about through work and it asks us to choose a project to evaluate or to start to think about evaluating I've only just started the course and this is the one I'm thinking of so I'm lucky because my occupational therapist colleague suggested we do a measure at the start of this this one we've just uh well we're nearly at the end of it we're kind of doing it termly so at the
很多问题想问你，我对你说的每一件事都很感兴趣。我的一部分在想，你们在进行结果测量吗？你们在衡量变化吗？你们在展示成果吗？这是一个非常好的问题，也非常切中要点，因为我刚刚开始参加这个免费的评估入门课程，我是通过工作发现的。它要求我们选择一个项目进行评估，或者开始考虑评估。我才刚开始上课，这就是我正在考虑的项目。我很幸运，因为我的职业治疗师同事建议我们在课程开始时进行一次测量，我们现在快结束了，我们是按学期进行的，所以
end of this term before the summer holidays it will end and then we'll do the the assessment again so it was the core 10 don't know if you know that one but that was her suggestion i'm very grateful to her so hopefully we'll have a little bit of data we've also got the qualitative data um where we ask people to write some comments about whether they found it helpful or you know what was their experience amazing yeah always for anyone listening and for you in future if you're doing any sort of group or any sort of intervention or even just an assessment do outcome measures just get them done and then do them in the middle do them at the end and just just see if there's any change and you know if you even if you think I don't know that we've necessarily got time to do anything
在暑假前的这个学期末，课程就会结束，然后我们会再次进行评估。那是 CORE-10 量表，不知道你知不知道，那是她的建议，我很感激她。希望我们能得到一些数据。我们还有定性数据，我们要求人们写下一些评论，关于他们是否觉得有帮助，或者他们的体验是什么。太棒了。对于任何听众，以及你未来的工作，如果你在做任何小组或干预，甚至只是评估，一定要做结果测量。做完之后，在中间做一次，在结束时做一次，看看是否有变化。即使你认为自己没有时间去处理这些数据，
with those having the data is really important and if you ever get like a master's student or a summer placement student sometimes looking at that data can be a really nice short-term project for people as well so yes outcome measures are so important I don't use the core 10 but I do regularly use the full version um and i really like and so it's 34 questions for anyone that's not familiar with it i really like that it breaks down people's areas of um need into functioning risk problems and well-being and people actually really like that because you can say well actually you're doing really well here but we can see that for example, you're working really hard
拥有数据也非常重要。如果你有硕士生或暑期实习生，有时查看这些数据对他们来说也是一个很好的短期项目。所以，结果测量非常重要。我不使用 CORE-10，但我经常使用完整版，它有 34 个问题，对于不熟悉的人来说，我非常喜欢它将人们的需求领域分解为功能、风险、问题和幸福感。人们实际上非常喜欢这一点，因为你可以说：“好吧，你在这里做得很好，但我们可以看到，例如，你工作非常努力，
so that your functioning is actually intact. But, you know, with that amount of problems pressing on you, that must be really exhausting. They're like, yes. So, yeah, I love outcome measures. And in terms of you being a yoga teacher, did you pitch to the organization or did you see an advert and think, oh, be good for that I'll apply for that which way around did it work? So it was me it was me suggesting it was when I was still working as a peer support worker in the community and I just thought oh this is something extra I can offer so I suggested it to my team and they took me up on it. Yeah. And it's been a bit of a headache.
所以你的功能实际上是完好的。但是，面对这么多压力，这一定非常令人疲惫。”他们会说：“是的。”所以，我喜欢结果测量。关于你作为瑜伽老师，你是向机构推销的，还是看到广告觉得“哦，这不错，我申请试试”？是哪种方式？是我主动建议的。当时我还在社区担任同伴支持工作者，我只是觉得这是我可以提供的额外服务，所以我向团队建议了，他们采纳了。是的，这确实有点让人头疼。
Tell you what the most headachy part of it is the organizing the venue, paying the invoice, all that sort of behind the scenes stuff that you don't appreciate takes a lot of time and a lot of work. Well, I'm sure you appreciate, but, you know, people in general don't see that behind the scenes side. And also kind of taking referrals, contacting the participants, reminding them, sending letters, all of that, it's a lot of admin. So actually now this programme, it's part of a bigger group program. It has an administrator now. So that makes things a lot easier.
我告诉你最头疼的部分是什么：组织场地、支付发票，所有那些幕后的事情，你可能没意识到这需要花费大量时间和精力。好吧，我相信你明白，但普通人看不到幕后的那一面。还有接收转诊、联系参与者、提醒他们、寄信，所有这些都是大量的行政工作。所以现在这个项目是更大的小组计划的一部分，现在有专门的行政人员了，这让事情变得容易多了。
But yeah. Absolutely. I remember when I was working in the NHS and the first time someone asked me for a purchase order number, I was like, I don't even know what that is. It sounds like it's going to be quite a lengthy process. Okay. So, yeah, I've definitely learned more about that in private practice but yes things in the NHS often don't hold in any large organization don't happen overnight do they and there's many many people involved in the process that in order for things to be rubber stamped okay so we've covered so much um such an interesting useful episode okay so work-life
但确实。我记得我在 NHS 工作时，第一次有人问我要采购订单号，我当时想：“我甚至不知道那是什么。”听起来这将是一个非常漫长的过程。好的，我在私人执业中确实学到了更多，但在 NHS 或任何大型组织中，事情往往不会一夜之间发生，对吧？为了盖章批准，过程中涉及很多人。好的，我们聊了很多，这是一个非常有趣且实用的节目。好的，工作与生活
balance is so key and you've obviously indicated you've got a real passion for reducing um potential for vicarious trauma even applying for the declincide can be a pretty tricky process and some people do burn out and that's not ideal what advice would you offer for anybody um to you know to reduce burnout yeah that's such a great question because um thinking back to my early experiences I think probably what I was experiencing was burnout actually and I always felt like I had to be doing more reading more you know using my spare time to study more and I just got really sick of it so now I do not do that at all I try to keep my work to the most part into my work hours and the rest of time, I pursue the things that I'm really interested in.
平衡是关键，你显然表达了对减少替代性创伤潜力的真正热情。即使是申请临床心理学博士（DClinPsy）也可能是一个非常棘手的过程，有些人会精疲力竭，这并不理想。你会给任何人什么建议来减少职业倦怠呢？这是一个非常好的问题。回想我早期的经历，我想我当时经历的可能就是职业倦怠。我总是觉得我必须做更多、读更多，利用业余时间学习更多，我真的厌倦了。所以现在我根本不那样做了。我尽量把工作限制在工作时间内，其余时间，我追求我真正感兴趣的事情。
And that just makes me a more well-rounded, happier person, for sure. And with the yoga, when I was doing my yoga teacher training, as part of our course, we were basically to pass the course, we were told you should be practicing six days a week. That doesn't mean you have to do an hour's class six days a week, but you should be doing a little bit of something yoga related every day. Maybe it's five minutes of breathing. Maybe it's reading a chapter of a yoga book but something just keep doing something six days a week um so since since doing this I really notice a difference on the days when I haven't done any yoga I noticed that the gap in between something happening and me reacting what you I think would refer to as our window of tolerance I noticed that gap is much smaller I will snap much faster if I haven't done that kind of self-awareness you know
这肯定让我成为了一个更全面、更快乐的人。关于瑜伽，我在接受瑜伽教师培训时，作为课程的一部分，为了通过考试，我们被告知应该每周练习六天。这并不意味着你必须每天上一小时的课，但你应该每天做一点与瑜伽相关的事情。也许是五分钟的呼吸，也许是读一章瑜伽书，但总之要坚持每天做一点。自从这样做以来，我真的注意到了区别。在那些我没有做瑜伽的日子里，我注意到从事情发生到我做出反应之间的间隔——也就是你所说的“容纳之窗”——我注意到那个间隔小得多。如果我没有进行那种自我意识的练习，
coming back to just noticing what's going on for me in my body in my life so I'd say just like I said about you and you just consistently putting out something every week it's little and often rather than one long class once a week whatever it is you decide is for you just doing it little and often you don't have it doesn't take a massive commitment but a little bit every day it's interesting you say about my consistency because um I like a streak I find it easier to go for streaks um so um if I was to miss a week I may miss a month you know so I'm just I just keep going keep going consistently but um I realized on Friday I've been trying to work sort of quite hard to get an article finished that I was writing and I realized that I hadn't actually edited the podcast episode for this week and I suddenly
回到仅仅注意到我的身体和生活中发生了什么，我会更容易发火。所以我想说，就像我说的关于你每周坚持发布内容一样，是“积少成多”，而不是每周一次的长课程。无论你决定做什么，只要坚持“积少成多”。不需要巨大的承诺，每天一点点就好。你提到我的坚持很有趣，因为我喜欢保持连贯性，我发现保持连贯更容易。所以，如果我错过了一周，我可能会错过一个月。所以我只是保持前进，保持连贯。但是，周五我意识到，我一直在努力完成我正在写的一篇文章，我意识到我实际上还没有编辑本周的播客剧集，我突然……
thought right I'll just record a really quick one just so that I've done it and so it's consistent and so it's done and it's out there and then I realized that I had already recorded one that I needed to edit so I just edited that quite quickly and got it done but I almost just you know do you remember that episode you might not you might not be around in those days um there was an episode called I can't be bothered something something like that so honest I think that's really important to be honest as well yeah but it crops up you know so I'm going to make this into a topic because some days you'll be like yes I'm really lucky to have this assistant job or to be a trainee but I can't be bothered I'd rather be in bed reading you know
我想着好吧，我还是录一个简短的吧，这样我就完成了，保持一致性，做完发布出去。然后我意识到我已经录好了一个需要剪辑的，于是我就很快把它剪辑完成了。但我差点就……你知道吗，你还记得那一集吗？你可能不记得了，那时候你可能还没关注。有一集叫《我不想做某事》之类的。说实话，我觉得诚实也很重要。是的，这种情况经常出现，所以我打算把它作为一个话题，因为有时候你会觉得，是的，我很幸运能得到这份助理工作，或者成为一名实习生，但我就是不想做，我宁愿躺在床上看书，你知道的。
and yes there's just some something about that is about being authentic and you know whilst we do love our career we also love time in a hammock you know should so we can bring our energy back to the role right yeah you can't give from an empty cup is that the same yeah it is and it's absolutely true um i could speak to you for hours and hours fiona but um yeah the audience might like quite quite like our episodes punchy um and pithy so um thank you so much for reaching out it's been an incredibly useful episode and um yeah do stay in my world let me know of any other future topic or episodes that you think you might find helpful um and yeah it's just been a real privilege thank you so much thank you mariam thanks a lot oh what an incredible guest what an incredible episode i hope you found
是的，这其中有一些关于真实性的东西。你知道，虽然我们热爱我们的职业，但我们也喜欢在吊床上休息的时间，这样我们才能恢复精力投入到工作中，对吧？是的，你不能从空杯子里倒水，是这样吗？是的，确实如此。菲奥娜，我可以和你聊上几个小时，但听众可能更喜欢我们简洁明了的节目。所以，非常感谢你的参与，这是一期非常有用的节目。请继续关注我，如果有任何未来想探讨的话题或节目建议，请告诉我。这真的是一种荣幸，非常感谢。谢谢玛丽安，非常感谢。哦，多么棒的嘉宾，多么棒的一期节目，我希望你从中获得了
so much value in it we realized in our post-recording chat that we didn't get around to talking about the dynamics of being supervised by people who ordinarily you might well be younger than but you might well be older than them there might be different dynamics and so if that's something you like to explore please do reach out and we can get you on an episode that said if you've got ideas for future podcast episodes that you might find helpful, or if you think you might make a good guest for the podcast, then do get in contact with me. The easiest place to do that is probably on LinkedIn. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm also Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere else too. Do come along to the free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent.
很多价值。我们在录音后的聊天中意识到，我们还没来得及讨论被那些通常可能比你年轻，但也可能比你年长的人监督的动态。这其中可能存在不同的互动关系。所以，如果你想探讨这个话题，请联系我们，我们可以安排你参加一期节目。话虽如此，如果你对未来的播客节目有什么好的建议，或者你认为自己适合成为播客嘉宾，请务必与我联系。最简单的方式可能是在领英上。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我在其他平台上也叫玛丽安·特伦特博士。欢迎加入我们的免费Facebook群组，即“玛丽安·特伦特博士的心理学追求者社区”。
And do please rate and review this podcast if you are listening to it on either Spotify or Apple. And if you're watching on YouTube, go on, do your thing. Subscribe, like and comment. It would make my day. Do please be kind to yourselves be kind to others too i will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast which will be along like clockwork from 6 a.m on monday take care day. Take care. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast.
如果你在Spotify或Apple上收听本播客，请务必评分和评论。如果你在YouTube上观看，来吧，做你该做的事。订阅、点赞并评论。这会让我开心一整天。请善待自己，也要善待他人。我期待在下一期《心理学追求者播客》中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点准时更新。保重。有这个播客陪伴，你离获得资格就不远了。这就是《心理学追求者播客》。
With Dr. Marianne Durant. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我觉得书中关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。各种各样的途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有所谓的完美路径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我强烈推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来了。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。